what makes a great processor in that
oh if you just look at its performance
versus everybody else
it's you know the size of it the you
know usability of it
so it's not specific some kind of
element that makes it beautiful it's
just like literally just
raw performance is that how you think
about processors
it's just like raw performance of course
it's like a horse race the fastest one
wins
now you don't care how
the fastest in the environment like
right you know for years you made the
fastest one you could and then people
started to have power limits
so then you made the fastest at the
right power point and then
and then when we started doing
multiprocessors like
if you could scale your processors more
than the other guy you could be 10
faster on like a single thread but you
have more threads
so there's lots of variability and then
arm
really explored like you know they have
the a series and the r
series and the m series like a family of
processors for all these different
design points from like unbelievably
small and simple
and so then when you're doing the design
it's sort of like this big palette of
cpus
like they're the only ones with a
credible you know top to bottom pallet
and what do you mean incredible uh top
to bottom well there's people who make
microcontrollers that are small but they
don't have a fast one there's people
make fast processors but don't have a
little a medium one or a small one
you